as for this a-lister Johnny Depp today
he's firing off on his career highs and
lows and the effects of Amber Heard when
you're asked to resign from a film
you're doing because of
something that is merely a bunch of kind
of vowels and consonants floating in the
air yeah you feel a bit boycotted do I
feel boycotted no no
not at all I don't feel boycotted by
Hollywood because I don't think about it
I don't have much further need for
Hollywood myself the least important
thing to me is becoming famous and being
well known
mirroring what he told ET back in 1988 a
seemingly defiant death not only showed
up 40 minutes late to a press conference
he also stuck his tongue out at a wall
of screaming photographers and goofed
off with a cast and crew of Jean DeBerry
which opened the canned Film Festival
yesterday Johnny got teary during this
seven minute standing ovation it's the
actor's first major film in three years
after a career downfall amid his ex's
abuse allegations which he's denied next
for Depp he set to direct a film
starring Al Pacino his first movie
directorial role in 26 years but he says
don't call all this a comeback I keep
wondering about the word comeback
because I didn't go anywhere maybe
people stopped calling out of whatever
their their fear was at the time well
Priscilla Presley is also setting the
record straight after ending her legal
battle with Riley Keough over Lisa
Marie's multi-million dollar estate I
want to make clear there was never any
lawsuit filed against my beloved
granddaughter we are pleased that we
resolved this together that's what
Elvis's ex told E.T just hours after
reaching a settlement with Riley she
previously challenged the validity of
Lisa Marie's will which left Riley in
control but Priscilla calls her legal
filing a quote request for document
interpretation the family's happy and
United both parties asked a judge to
seal the terms of yesterday's settlement
a hearing for that is scheduled for
August 4th
foreign